[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia a propósito del día mundial del
medio ambiente este 5 de junio de 2021
haremos un breve recuento de cuando en
la historia se empezó a hablar de
calentamiento global porque cambió su
apelativo por el de cambio climático y
finalmente su re bautismo por el de
emergencia climática en parte por las
crecientes denuncias de decenas de miles
de activistas que consideran el cambio
climático como un eufemismo y exigen
además a las grandes multinacionales
parar la emisión de gases efecto
invernadero la primera persona en
alertar públicamente sobre un impacto
del co2 en la atmósfera fue svante
arrhenius con un científico y profesor
sueco lo hizo en abril de 1896 con un
ensayo denominado la influencia del
ácido carbónico en el aire sobre la
temperatura del suelo pero en su estudio
eludió atribuir a los combustibles
fósiles la causa de un futuro
calentamiento global
para finales del siglo 19 dado que el
desarrollo industrial no parecía
impactar el equilibrio y la armonía de
la naturaleza nadie tomo en serio la
teoría de arrhenius pero 42 años después
el mundo científico presto atención
sobre esta materia al estudio de un
ingeniero inglés llamado google tubert
calendar su principal aporte fue
vincular el aumento de la temperatura
global del planeta en 50 años con el
incremento del 10 por ciento en las
concentraciones de dióxido de carbono en
la atmósfera
paradójicamente calendar consideró este
calentamiento progresivo como algo bueno
pues según él retrasaría la llegada de
la siguiente glaciación ahora termina la
segunda guerra mundial y a lo largo del
período de posguerra conocido como la
guerra fría la producción industrial se
elevó a su máxima potencia a mediados de
la década de 1970 por primera vez la
comunidad científica expuso abiertamente
el término calentamiento global y para
1988 cuando se evidenció el año más
caluroso en la historia de la tierra
jamás registrado los periódicos del
mundo comenzaron a vincularlo con algo
llamado efecto invernadero de manera que
para finales de la década de 1980 y
comienzos de 1990 líderes de la talla de
ronald reagan y margaret thatcher
incluyeron en sus agendas políticas al
calentamiento global como una amenaza
para el planeta un discurso sin
precedentes que adoptó mayor relevancia
en 1995 cuando un grupo internacional de
científicos publicó por primera vez la
influencia humana indiscutible del
llamado efecto invernadero se hablaba
por primera vez del riesgo de un agujero
en la capa de ozono producto de los
gases industriales que permiten un mayor
ingreso de la radiación emitida por el
sol
las alarmas la organización de las
naciones unidas llevó a cabo en el año
de 1995 una convención por el cambio
climático en berlín convención presidida
por una joven angela merkel quien
profesaba la necesidad de que las
naciones exportadores de petróleo
redujeron considerablemente las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
di a nosotros y las naciones
industrializadas debemos cambiar nuestra
idea de lo que vemos como la buena vida
vendan
con el paso de los años el discurso
científico sobre el calentamiento global
fue cambiando de curso la culpa ya no lo
tenían los spray o los aerosoles usados
en casa sino los combustibles fósiles
como el dióxido de carbono el metano y
el óxido nitroso producido por las
grandes multinacionales como lo
demostraron para finales del siglo 20 el
centro de investigación de hidráulica
británica el centro de investigación del
medio ambiente de oxford y las
supercomputadoras del instituto de
impactos climáticos en hamburgo y postal
creo que deberíamos tomar precauciones
sensatas con anticipación si no lo
hacemos la preocupación es que el
suministro de agua se pondrá en riesgo
la seguridad alimentaria se reducirá y
los ecosistemas podrían verse afectados
es cruise baby jane el término
calentamiento global que se refiere sólo
a la temperatura de la superficie de la
tierra pronto mutó al llamado cambio
climático que además de incluir el
calentamiento advierte sobre los efectos
secundarios que tanto exponen los
científicos de su
pero la barrera de los dos grados
celsius es decir el desabastecimiento
mundial de comida el deshielo de los
glaciares la consecuente inundación de
las costas y la extinción de miles de
especies ante tales pronósticos y
habiendo el servicio europeo copernicus
registrado en los años más calurosos de
la historia del planeta en la década de
2010 a 2020 la onu combinó el denominado
acuerdo de parís este acuerdo firmado en
2016 es el sucesor del protocolo de
kioto de 1997 en el cual las naciones
del mundo y en especial las naciones
industrializadas se comprometieron a
reducir las emisiones de gases efecto
invernadero para mantener por debajo de
los dos grados celsius la temperatura
global pero ante gobiernos que desoyeron
dichos compromisos como el de donald
trump quien se retiró en su momento del
acuerdo de parís la voz de activistas
internacionales como el de la joven
sueca greta fiver cobraron protagonismo
mundial
como ellas son decenas de miles de
activistas quienes juegan un papel muy
importante al calor de las
manifestaciones y movilizaciones para
que las grandes empresas reduzcan sus
emisiones de carbono y así minimicen el
riesgo de escenarios apocalípticos para
la supervivencia en la tierra una
exigencia que de acuerdo con muchos
expertos está lejos de lograrse ante el
incesante comercio del petróleo el
carbón y sus derivados para satisfacer
el consumo energético mundial así
concluimos hoy andrés suárez jaramillo
gracias por compartir y comentar estas
historias que las encuentran en los
programas de france 24 punto com
[Música]